well Wendy started this and you know
this was based on the book that Ron had
written which was published what two
years ago yeah so did you up get an
option in the book before it was
published or when he was telling you
about it yeah so Ron had been telling
you about this story for a long time I
but when he was it was he was done with
the book when it was in sort of in the
he sent me the galleys and he said I
think this would make a great film I
read the book and I was just immediately
blown away i optioned it right away for
the documentary rights and and then a
month later I was um I was at riverview
filming my first shoot was Owens was the
Valentine's Day dance and it was Owen
and Emily and they were so in love and
they were so physical and I was just
like so so so surprised that sort of
started the journey but I would imagine
you know kiss the movie follows him in
this really pivotal time in his life of
getting out of school and on his own
which was not the know so did you change
once you've got and started filming yeah
it was really important to me that it
wasn't just a retelling of the book
which is all in the past that so I
picked up with a book left off and so
Owen was about to go through this really
transformative year in his life where he
was about to graduate here's graduating
from Carly from college from a special
school for children people with autism
and he was about to graduate from
college he was about to become
independent and move in on his own and
he had fallen in love and I thought
these are for me it was never up some
about autism it was a coming-of-age
story about a young man and so it was
all these Universal points I was and I
was going to hit all these Universal
beats everyone graduates everyone
hopefully everyone falls in love you
know everyone has a their first break
heartbreak all those beats that are
universal that that we can all connect
to because it was all about you know
humanizing I when it was all about
really bringing showing the world from
Owens point of view with the whole film
is to really show from the inside
looking out not from the outside
where his films about people with
disabilities and I've made one is really
about the outside looking in its really
and this was about youth bringing the
audience into Owens world into Owens
deep into Owens mine and experiencing
the world through hit through his eyes
so that went by the end of the film you
really know exactly who he is and and
how he sees the world in the beginning
when you see him sort of pacing and self
talking you're a little uncomfortable I
was a little I was uncomfortable when i
first started filming but as you get to
know and as you realize there's this
rich beautiful world that he's created
for himself and that this is someone who
grew up on a diet of myth and fable
these Disney stories are really classics
fables that brain told for thousands of
years Disney just you know updates then
rips them off and and so but he's the
heat so those but those stories are what
we need to make us human you know that's
how we that's how we connect with each
other is through myth and fable and
glory so Owen grew up on a diet of this
and he too makes him really why's it
makes him an expert on what it means to
be you in human so he taught me so much
about filmmaking and he taught me so
much as a person how about you were
saying you taught you a lot about
filmmaking it was how did he teach you
about them well so so you know the
hero's journey I you know Owen is an
expert on sort of the hero's journey and
I realized that Owen was taking his own
heroes Jerry and and I had to sort of
figure out you know how am I going to
tell this I'm working with someone who
is autistic who necessarily I can't
necessarily sit down and ask questions
so I came up with various devices i used
anantara Tron which is a camera that was
invented by errol morris and it's a
camera it's basically it's kind of sort
of like a teleprompter setup ok and the
camera so you're looking directly into
the lens of the subject is looking on at
a screen and he's looking directly into
the lens of the camera and so Owen spent
his life looking at a televisions so
that just so he's when he looks at me on
I'm in the other room he's looking at me
on a screen and
he can then look at me and totally look
me in the eye and totally engage with me
Wow and that's how I was able to have
and he's the only one in the film that
looks directly at the audience so you
immediately have this connection so then
I had this little clicker and I would
ask him a couple questions and then I
would click and show him a Disney clip
on the screen so Owen is interacting
with the Disney clip and the audience is
in a sense inside the Disney clip and in
a sense inside his head I felt watching
this movie that he knows more about
emotions and what you need to what makes
your heart work and the emotions and
what is good and bad in the world then
most people who were considered you know
that dirt unit typical yeah yeah no Owen
is so wise it's so wise and as we've
been going around to festivals and doing
interviews with the press we were doing
an interview with the LA Times and Owen
walks in the room and the reporter
sitting there and he says um and she's
like Owen it's so nice to meet you
you're so famous and he's like because
he's like you know um I'm not a
celebrity celebrities are out for
themselves and I'm just someone who's
being celebrated this year oh I thought
was so amazing it came out his parents
were like what would that come and I was
reading it you that a lot of the doctors
you know didn't want they wanted to take
away everything that he loved yeah
because they said now why did they want
it this as I said that wasn't going to
help him or um well I always say this is
much of film as it is a film about the
power of story ooh a film a
coming-of-age story it's also a film
about you know parenting right and it's
a film about love and they they loved
him that they were going to find any way
they could to connect to their son and
so what the what the doctors told them
was that you shouldn't encourage someone
with a child with autism affinity they
call it an affinity you shouldn't
encourage that you should use that as
sort of a reward and you should be
should restrict that and that was the
thinking and so but they did
they did just the opposite because they
realize it was an avenue to get to their
son and connect with him and because of
that they've sort of started a whole new
movement in the autism community and I
really world called affinity therapy and
the conference that you at the end of
the film the conference that Owen goes
to in Paris and makes the speech is the
first conference in the world on
affinity therapy because of the book
because my god thus us guys at what how
did you get how did you get the clips I
mean did you and your producer have to
like go and say I was like presented
treatment and exactly so um yes Sean
Bailey who's the president of Disney
Productions sort of helped us and he's a
on the board of trustees at Sundance and
keri putnam at sundance introduced us
and we had to go and we had There was
all the heads of all the different
departments of Disney so it was disney
head of Disney marketing and legal and
animation and I and I had clips i had
disney club clips i had shot graduation
i had graduation clips and and sort of
photos in home movies and i had these
index cards and I was shaking and I had
to go take them on a journey through the
film and I was a nervous wreck i think i
would get through it and I because so
much was at stake for the film and Frank
its kitchen if you couldn't show the
clips so I was shaking and I am by the
time the lights came up they were all in
tears and I had them I was like I have
them I wanted to ask you how did know
the whole thing about the the animation
and bringing to life the his story and
the protect and you went to France to
have it the animes elana me i was
looking at um you know I always wanted
to bring the last chapter in the book is
the Owen wrote and created the sidekick
story which was just luckily yeah and
it's joy and his monsters that he
creates all correspond to the challenges
he has in his life so I always wanted to
bring that to life and I'm so I was
looking at different types of animation
and I loved what the French were doing
with 2d animation
so I went to this company mcgough in
Paris and the guy who runs it as a sky
Philippe who spent 15 years living on a
boat in the sin and he did despicable me
and he kind of is like character in this
video me and Philippe just fell in love
with the story and he his you know he
does big mostly 3d animation big films
and he had sold his company to Universal
but kept a small group of animators in
this little office next to the Eiffel
Tower it was all like very magical and
I'm and he's like I said I taught I
talked him into doing this and he said
um Roger when people finish this film
they will pray to be autistic and I I
loved that concept I love that idea that
people were going to that Owen that is
maybe we're the ones on the outside
maybe Owens world oh and the six on a
higher plane Owen is just it you know
his world is so free so free r and it's
so beautiful and creative and maybe
we're the ones and I just love that
concept and he put together a team of
just amazing young French animators and
we really when working together with a
Skywalker Sound and our sound designer
el Nelson we just created you know all
the the music the composition was this
young kid Dylan Stark was the same age
was the same age as oh and it was 23
years old from Portland Oregon he's
electronic music all that music is Owen
self talking the sound of VHS
fast-forwarding and rewinding that Dylan
created a musical composition it's it's
yes and so it was about taking all of
the things that I went ahead and turning
that into music the sound design for me
that's why this theater has great so I'm
cell system because the sound design is
was as important as a visual stuff that
by the time you're in the animated short
you're in this ethereal you're in this
world you're deep into his mind and his
reality in his world and and that was to
me that was so exciting to create and oh
and I'm sure just couldn't believe when
he shot was amazed the first time is on
and he actually hugged me and no one
doesn't hug and he
hugged me and he said I love it and it's
you know he always says it's amazing to
see his vision sort of come to life on
the big screen well it certainly did and
he's just to see now you did I just
thought this was really a terrific movie
like this and I really appreciate coming
out and today and thank you guys for
coming thank you guys thank you